hi welcome to now playing I'm Mary I'm
joined by so many talented co-workers we
got Eric Tay he's all
right that's so nice got Rob we got Max
oh hey hi and we're going to be playing
a,1 spikes so it's actually I didn't
know that it actually had Co-op uh I
thought it might be competitive death
but it's kind of kind of similar to
previous games that we'
played uh where it's you kind of all try
to achieve the same but if you die
you're dead we can't really affect each
other too much besides stunning each
other a little bit can see hey don't get
on that hey how
you you wait call your color out yeah
call the color I'm
green I'm
white that's so rude I'm red
and I am uh yellow I guess I'm jumpy Meo
over here so this one thing that you can
do supposed to not jump on that I made
it so you can affect each other in that
way a you are everyone for themselves
she won't she won't know though yeah
take that if you make it to the end you
kind of win the round but at the end of
the day we should all be like kind of
working towards a common goal what is
going on here yeah we got to there's too
many
wild all right why don't we work
together hope you die Kish Jesus that's
not a good start Jesus hey she threw a
knife at him and it caused him to fall
on a spike retribution there go the
Australian Mario Brothers I'm just going
to beat this while you're all dead yeah
do it green ranger best I feel that's
not what Co-op is about at all no look
at him dancing he's just he's making fun
of
us okay no one's G it all right let do
this together go
go watch out there's a spike there right
yeah is you got triggered though Tri
it than so much he sacrificed himself
for the greater good out for that laying
on a grenade watch out for that
one obviously Max is a superior at this
game to for that I like the idol the
idol is just basically dancing like that
the other one's better though wait for
wait for wait yeah you got to wait a
little bit long does the like m
don't know don't know don't know I'm
just real good at dancing he doesn't do
anything after that so how come the
Spikes have blood on them before you
kill yourself on them so many way to run
into it way to run into it okay let's
wait all right
go I'm not triggering it it's really
hard to like see
yourself in all the people that we have
going on okay so wait for it scorpion
take shot do you got to trigger it
scorpion kind of got to trigger it no
what you're going to do is you're going
to do the big jump over there and give
it three shots exactly like that three
shots tight boom boom boom there's a
spike on this
one oh blew it wa twice [__] there a
long job I keep foret okay there's one
right below right that's right you don't
have technically you don't have to go
there but I think later on we will see
if you look down the bottom right I
think we're going to need to bring this
thing that's underneath me so that we
can jump up to the next One D
complicated see what I'm saying all
right yeah yeah yeah I'll see if can you
jump in there and push it out go on jump
there you go there you go there you go
good work oh wait we got to go back you
got to go back yeah there's a spike
right there patience everyone if you
drop that box on my head will I die I
don't know why don't you find out no you
you find out oh so now you got to go
back through again back I got to go all
the way back that's you team player
that's you
you you think there's a spike right
there though on that Landing platform
probably not you get big jump there you
you got it you got it it was watch out
for the one below the spikes there
though yeah nice one very good oh ah she
knew it there could be spikes on all of
these right here though you think so
there could be and that guy might might
might shoot I think it will all right
you can test it out for
Freedom oh no okay okay don't die Kish
why would you put yourself up there cuz
this is a secret that's a weird spot
make sure you get that key though all
right so you need to get the key in
order to beat the level every level this
guy shoots right yeah I don't know
you're the one that fell down there I
don't remember nope I'm scared that guy
might okay so you need to get to the
door in the top right yeah we have the
key either of us can do it come to me
I'm dancing remember the guy on the left
will shoot at you there was a spike on
this like green like that thing
shoots now do I inherit the key yes you
have to okay and also what's your plan
I'm dead but I just want you to know
that when you throw your knife you can
actually the blow dart yeah so if you
jump up there turn around and or you do
a double jump you try to avoid it so
it's it's all on you Kish no
pressure it's so fast it's so fast it's
all right all right oh Wild Card
move it's every man for themselves all
right I got it this time got a feel game
here okay so just one oh we did
it oh it's only two I thought it was
three it was three you missed the
here really slowing us down
here just do the big there do there you
go okay so we're doing the same thing
someone's got to do the block all right
looks like it's
Max Max is this you it looks like yeah
I'm probably the best of the three of us
here wa whoo wo w w of the three of us
you're dead okay fair enough quit your
complaining wait I could have smushed me
all right maybe he wanted you out the
way it's so fast those uh that [__] it
was way faster than I thought it would
be all right J all right so do you want
me to go down and get the key yeah do
you want me to for just so you know I
don't know if you guys noticed earlier
but that platform will drop so after you
get the key make sure you get you went
all the way through didn't you and you
didn't die are there spikes on those no
there were no spikes oh really no no no
I thought you were talking about down
there I don't want to push this into
that hole you need that to push you need
jump back so you just jump across then
jump back yep there you go all right I
did it um does that thing shoot at me no
no you can y up
there oh I don't remember those I forgot
about those okay it's all up to Max it's
all up to you Max
you oh I like it oh I
like you should have jumped I didn't
think he was going to shoot again it's
way faster than you think it will be I
just didn't think he was going to shoot
again the second time so quickly all
right I feel like we've learned a
lot and now we should be really good is
there a spike on this one yes there
is hey red come over here oh
[__] come on I'm dead where' you go I
think you guys are you screened out F oh
why do we wait Max I don't know why did
you
wait this is not
Co-op you guys are what you hey we're
doing a we're doing a great we're doing
are you going to go or me you get the
key all right all right fair enough he's
selling you out no he did it before he
could do it again I just trust the team
he trusts himself to get up okay he
trusts himself to not die this time uhoh
don't die on the spikes man was it just
like do I go real fast or do I I don't
know how you did it I died I don't know
how I got up there actually well just do
it I think you just did it yeah I did
all right so one of you guys sacrif how
about how about I jump and oh
crap come on how about you what I was
going to say how about I okay I was
going to say how about you jump and I
jump and shoot I was yeah exactly
exactly and then you ran into the spikes
sorry I just kind of booked it there all
right Rob I expect you to get a little
further than you yeah me
too oh why would you do that
Eric worst Move Along
scorpion also hello chat I I have the
laptops in front of me I'm I'm trying to
uh monitor
it you get further forgetting about that
no I died the exact same spot all right
are you going to do it push in
the all right I'll get the key as as
discussed we're getting really good at
this level yeah we are we know the the
intricacies I wish just like to say that
I've made it to the end every single
time oh shut up that is the most least
Co-op thing to say all right go get the
key I would just like to say of all
these shitty people I'm the best that's
right congratulations get the key get
the
key okay so on this one after the SP I
just booked it you just go yeah left
there you go watch watch out for the
just sacrifice himself okay so you want
me what do you want me to do I'm just
going to do whatever you tell me to do
even if that kills me I can jump to the
left and just Spam and just just do that
hit as many jump to the left and spam is
just Spam spam spam it all right you
want to count to the three you go cuz if
you're spamming it's safe for me to go
no matter what or if I die then it's
dangerous for you you should be ready to
jump over one blow dart at least that's
my guess I age my concern is that the
door is not open yet oh so you can't
just Spam up I mean cuz don't doesn't
the door normally open once we yeah it
takes like a also there's a funny
looking block there's a funny looking
block to the right of the door there I I
don't like we've never gotten this far
and I feel like we have to make an
effort you're going to jump to the left
and spam spam spam all right here we go
do
it I died he had so much faith that it's
on you it's on you the plan the plan
didn't work out do a small job and see
it yeah there you go wow see get in
there yeah there you go there go okay I
did not do well it's all right you know
I think I jumped too high and it shot my
feedies your fees little booties okay oh
I think they're spikes I think they're
spikes yeah those are spikes it's a lot
Whitey definitely
are what is that oh my God you you've
ruined it for the rest of us I didn't
know here we
go there's nothing you can do you cannot
make that just die you can't make it
don't be a hero okay all right let's go
together watch okay watch for the top
block I died to that thing it comes down
the you see that one the the darker gray
one small jump there that one falls and
hits you in the head cuz I tried to jump
across so so wait for it you got to wait
for that thing to fall I don't know
we're going to find out somebody to
trigger it all right so let's count on
the count of three go on three one two
three I died good work Mary good work
you guys no no no no get
that what you supposed to do there not
go down there not at all huh I don't
know
count all right one two
3 oh I took it for the team thank you
one of you guys can stay okay there you
go do we just get it and come back how
do you do that don't hit me I okay I
think you can I don't know if you're why
jumping I'm going to do it can you shoot
the block shoot the block right there no
get out of my way oh look at that loose
one oh let me maybe I can go around
maybe if you stayed there I can jump up
and break that one for you so you or at
least push one down and I can get yeah
do that let's do
that
how far can you go without we'll find
out that's going to I'm going to go
first hey let me go first cuz you're
better and if I die good call I like
that dagger give her a dagger shut
you're so lucky you're
dead
Okay work Mary I know
oh confidence come
on this is looking really good sorry
come I didn't know that would happen I
didn't know that would happen shoot that
thing can you break it no no I have a
feeling those have spikes but I don't
know probably all of those have
spikes oh shoot shoot the block to the
left can you shoot that
thing Rob could you rob you got to come
get it you can make that you got to come
get it man could you could you rob you
got to come get it all right see what
happens should I do a long J this is all
for one
life get get
get can you make that jump I don't think
either I might be able to make that
should I do from here no I think you're
going to have I think you have to fall
and jump but I don't know if you can
make it like a running start off the
edge of that one Spike block I don't
know I wish I could oh yeah Yi oh wow
all right so I think we should all go at
different times and see who makes
it I'm going to go I'm going to go after
the second Spike cuz I think there's a
break after the second Spike so it's one
two go
good
PNY jump so let's not go one by one got
that you got that work damn this one so
oh wait wait that was good okay all
right count of three one two go oh F my
life wait I lost track of who I was
because we all look the same same
thing oh my goodness that was so you you
wait for that thing to fall well
obviously you don't headbutt
it oh you we had time that rock it
wasn't it wasn't weight sensitive it was
time sensitive I think it's time
sensitive fair enough Spike come out of
you where is it timer you have to
trigger it so if you just jump yeah
you're
good remember there's spikes on there my
heart yeah okay so I once I get up there
I'll shoot it okay yep yep yep yep jump
yep fine he can make it from there
anyway yes he can and he will it's okay
we don't need that thing need it you
don't
need you shoot it the key you need the
key but you don't need that jump there
you go break it'll break yeah okay watch
out
okay I saw the Scorpion he saw that
coming saw the Scorpion watch
out I saw the Scorpion should I just not
even go down there what can you land on
you're not going to be able to jump can
you land on their heads no no no you're
not going to be able to make if I hit
down and shoot does it shoot down no no
just shoot shoot shoot there you go okay
oh nice great my ears
so sorry to headphone users good God
turn down your volume R your ears
there's probably spikes on the top of
that block too my heart can't take this
I have a
condition okay o he wants you how is she
going make jump he smells you know what
I bet I bet you weren't supposed to
trigger the thing you got to keep it up
maybei wow so did she actually step on
the Scorpion she did it she The Edge the
corner to apologize to all headphone
users I'm really sorry wow I have a
heart wait wait hold the phone I have
seen this I have seen this one on a
stream let's discuss this
those blocks are coming down I don't
know how they come down though can we
just not hit the listen Whitey I think
you need it because it gives you blocks
to make it across oh more momentum so
who wants to just do it Rob and let pray
let's
pray all right ah okay so we learned
there learned that grass is good
oh how did you make that jump I don't
know I just I you just did the big jump
yeah I did the big I big jump running
jump do it did you run I ran
like and then up again okay now we got
to make this next jump is that a short
jump or AIG jump be a long jump that's a
big oh hey hey there hey easy
knifey Oh's trying Sho trying to shoot
the top yeah I can't get up there though
how can you do that someone's going to
have to come back someone's going to
have to come back and fall down and
shoot it and then then go back again to
I don't know I don't know I'm scared all
right I'm going to find out for you want
yeah why do you even need to let what
what is okay all right nothing happy I'm
kind of okay I feel like that one square
is only going to last so long yep you
guys both got to go or is it a
spike you coming are you just going to
wait possible spikes on all these blocks
I'm bored
go all right that's fine that's fine
that's F oh you can long jump I don't I
you can long jump that
oh not that's it son of that's it game
over game over man oh
die die already die I'm
try God calm down everyone can't die
when you're you're supposed to it's here
it's here where started yeah
right y ready for
this I'm going to do a bold move try it
do
it no you totally need that extra lift
I'm going to do the wrap around okay you
do what you want you guys ready for this
yep that's a mistake I'm bored oh no
there's an extra one I didn't know about
that one I was trying to style I was
trying to get some style points show off
I also wanted to read
chat are you oh you didn't you didn't
remember that go
no don't worry guys you got
this okay now you just got to you got to
B it you got to B it yeah yeah yeah okay
okay all right I think that thing used a
blow dart I'm pretty sure it's going to
be too fast I'm pretty sure got jump
jump yeah it's going to be triggered
when I jump which means it's going to
hit me when I land you do big jump up JP
big jump straight
up hopefully it goes under you I think
he just going to hit
me there you go yeah you don't have time
oh yeah
oh okay okay everyone It Well Done wow
all right it's okay the door's right
there you only got two scorpions get by
just take your time oh my goodness take
your time there you go okay don't even
go for the skull it's not even worth it
oh okay you got to make the jump you got
to make the jump there you go okay y
don't even worry about the skull we have
928 more spikes to go
TI oh yeah once
again coming up
strong my spirit fingers I'm going to
have a heart
attack Spirit fingers uh blow dart y yep
that's a thing I don't know where to oh
but okay the door is under us oh that's
weird so don't go down because that
Block's going to fall yeah good point we
have to go over the top watch out the
blow if you do a long jump it should go
under you and then you should land
safely so I think you guys should do yep
there you go yeah I have to keep jumping
and I'm not going to make it go go go go
where going
just back back back you got to hit that
last my goodness damn you just got to do
it that was hilarious all right it's
just like whoever makes
it that is tough oh good luck to you rob
you can make that jump sleep you're blew
it you're dead oh this is good we can we
can study the bottom side we can study
the bottom side okay so both what if you
shoot it will it fall if you shoot it no
the the
blocks all right Dam it have we learned
not much it's
like let's do one by one wait wait then
wait for us
no can't wiggle wiggle can't wiggle
wiggle
wiggle actually you know what hey how
about this what if go go go go go go go
your got now run back run back run back
trying I'm
trying we still got the key we you guys
still have the key yeah yeah yeah oh my
God my finger slipped off it's lost a
lot of gripping on the
stick I'm not going to how am I going to
possibly
the I lost my my it's the I get another
the
controller guys this is unreal there's
butter all over here but like how could
I possibly do that guy's going to shoot
immediately do the jump onto the block
and jump up right away and then jump
again I that's what I think I don't know
if it's quick enough if you die worst
case I think what we should do next time
is have someone go
there
believe believe that nice word believe
believe that you they so Naruto yeah oh
my goodness Believe It
Believe oh fire uh-oh w likeit
someone's up with this someone's up with
this [__] all right I'm going to
go oh that guy wait wait we're all going
to get shot as soon as that drops yep
you got to jump green get over there let
me catch up let me catch up I'm waiting
I'm waiting I'm waiting I'm not all
right we got to I died all right you say
one you push it I'll jump I'll react to
it who me you push it and die you push
it you push it and
die official lamb your plan hey he got
to where he needed to get to nice good
job good preemptive thinking are there
spikes though I don't know there's
probably like that circular one will
yeah yeah yeah the one you're about to
cross is probably and the one above it
might so careful have to just straight
book it book it oh but there's three of
them oh go go go go I like it he's
testing the waters yeah he's do he's
doing what IND oh there you go he's
doing what IND
would instead of there's butter on your
controller too
weird how do they expect us to do this
with all this oh wait wait wait wait I
made that mistake oh my I made that
mistake I
know wait for it I'm waiting let's be
kind okay who's doing it I don't know
I'll do it ready one two 3 [__] I died
work tough survive in my honor that's
all
right you got to come down here bro or I
guess I guess well not if you push it
whatever dude all right butter
fingers hey lay off my butter finger
dude you got to trigger that back up oh
man let's do it look it wait wait wait
there's fire there's fire there's fire
should I should I sacrifice myself the
we got to wait okay I mean we all know
how far I'm honest to God you don't yeah
like you guys don't have to push it
couldn't you just all jump from there I
I don't think you can that the small
jump I feel like you could all right
well I guess we could test it after this
fire there's no head room though go oh
yeah just stand
good spot go oh I'm scared oh
no why do you use your kniv how would
we got to run and shoot run and shoot
I've been laying off the knife care
don't do it there's some serious speed
going on here yep oh there it is all
right all right let's wait wait for it
two three go I'm dead I'm so dead oh I'm
alive no I'm so dead I'm the one who's
dead it's
it's really anyone's game on this one
all
right there you go don't go all the way
I'm scared wait for me yeah we will do
the small do the small jump small jump
small jump and then and
then's like what I'm I'm out here see
you I told jump over top there you go
there you go okay wait wait for now wait
for this one then you do long all right
we should go one
we should go one at a
time yeah shoot all the way down well
tell me your Technique here you wait
until what the top one you wait for the
yeah so after this bottom one goes right
the top one like you can jump down the
top one's going to go I don't think
there's no don't even ignore the bottom
one for the top one you go I don't F you
want to watch me I don't trust you once
you get up there you just got to start
shooting that there it is Sho yeah keep
going keep going oh yeah I I can stop it
here get far enough so that she can go
and just jump past it all all right give
me a second there it is now Mary
just damn sorry headphone users uh yeah
once again Mary see you I'm going to get
the mic away what if Rob screamed just
as badly as I no I'm pretty sure
I wait wait oh what what happened you
guys are mother happened you guys are
mother effort
patience it's me first guys it's always
me
first no really guys really just die
just
die you'll never make it why do I why
won't I make
it cuz your talent lies within us oh man
wait wait wait there you
go this is good
stuff hope you guys are excited for
another 45 minutes of this of constant
murder and death it's only been 15 and
screaming and peeking no no no oh oh
yeah go Indy oh look the timing the
timing is rough we're going to have to
learn piece of crap guys I got this I'm
real I got this you're going to step
away everyone Rob's going to die first
step away
everyone all let's go oh I'm so sorry
I'm so
sorry
of course Rob
do the team guys I apologize I'll do it
I'll do it I'll do it all
right go not too much there you go oh
fire you forgot about the fire yeah wait
I'm coming I'm not going anywhere this
is my crawl
space okay all right are you going to
watch me am I going to I'm going to try
to hold the try not to like completely
kill me like time going you can run
through me right we can clip through
each other so I can just stand there and
can't shoot through each other you can't
shoot through each other Friendly Fire
isn't
on give me a second oh it's so fast I'm
coming I tried to react to it shooting
but it comes out too fast right I'm
scared guess you just got to spam it
game
scared wait can you just I got this yeah
I'm just but you can't run oh can kind
of we can kind of w you can wait wait
for wait for him wait for wait for you
can make a couple pixels while shooting
this is the way you got to do it what
you doing what I'm just showing what
needs to be done why don't you live and
get there first before you show off oh
wow thanks all right who's calling it I
am one two
three oh I lived because ma took it for
me I got this guys I got
this there we go oh don't get
overzealous I
know there's so many of us oh we all did
it I'm so proud of you guys all right
who's going first I
am dude you were so close my butt it got
singed he wait for one away from me yeah
yeah okay she's
she's Can it
can I thought I could shoot wad you can
like w we discuss this where were you
you can waddle for hold the direction
hold the direction you you can make move
there you
go I think I think w
w hey next time when we get there I'll
just
gos I have no right to say anything what
we had an entire conversation about
whether or not to shoot through I
forgot he's never been that far he's
never been that far I got
we we discussed it as a group got a
answer who's calling it
one
one who goes on
one this mother did you not listen to
that let's go let's go this mother app
man I can't this mother ass man real
wild card I can't who goes on
one sh everyone Look Alive come on I'm
just GNA go I don't like you I'm staying
away from you okay okay stay away from
me it's good it's good oh no no okay
okay do we remember where the spikes are
okay there they're right there
okay that's
dirty wow that's a nasty one that's a
dirty dirty wait I was depressed Wait
For Me Oh I like
that I like
that careful ma said [__] [__] you guys
[__] any die for wait I'm coming nobody
trusts you God I know cuz of your
negligent Behavior it's cuz I'm
white isn't
it all right are you going to go I'll
support you are we waiting for this guy
I don't know I'll go and throw knives
but only one of us can do it okay fine
you're going to throw I'll be there in a
sec guys shut up Rob oh get away from me
I was past you you were in my way you
can't go past me the white guy always
waits he goes on one
apparently oh man okay go believe in
when his mouth is open go as soon as
it's closed oh
what what I'm
white this is about me being white isn't
it go push it all the
way oh I'm so sorry you guys
oh this is the first time we all live it
was me blame it on me I I didn't mean to
push it it just happened oh
Skypey oh God she wants to handle this
no we're just jumping over yeah push a
little further no easy man easy man what
no I know I'm know we going I don't want
to be in that situation what I don't
like being here with
them all right all right who's going I'm
waiting I'm just waiting this is the
first time I've been here
guys damn it good job oh God I'm glad
you're really supporting
me shut up you're going to
die isible you can't Hammer that down
the whole time screw up eventually so
bad Mary you got to
carious oh why why
why who goes on one
go on do your it's your time to shine
Rob easy easy easy does
it all right I'm going to go I'm going
to freaking go you do it you do
it okay okay looking good looking good
looking good
oh that was it are we
actually oh I couldn't oh come on so you
can't do that forever hold on hold on
guys guys hold on ad break we're going
to go to an ad break we're going to
compose
ourselves have a word from our sponsors
and hopefully wait wait watch this what
you're in the back okay how do you do
that one yeah how do you do that though
I feel like we should go to break yeah
we're going to break just just go to
break back I'm at the top right now and
I'm scared son of a Get Go use My
Sacrifice remember you die or something
cuz I I can't do this forever it's only
it's only hold on does that one even
shoot though it's not even shooting it's
screen don't worry about it I TR I don't
trust you you don't trust me I'm not
even doing anything well you die a lot
oh great rebuttal by Mary Kish see all
right so that one's going to go the
moment you well you're fine with the
spike
down I'm so scared progress progress
ladies and gentlemen there you
go okay okay what the fudge do I do you
go and you kind of got to like there's
fire throw knives back as you go no turn
around turn around oh good yeah go go go
but there's a fire oh you got to walk to
that one stone in the middle of the fire
turn around turn around turn around turn
around turn around wait how do I ruin
that stone tell me what to do you got to
step on it you got your weight is going
to carry you down your weight is going
to carry you down but it's not going to
be immediate yeah
oh oh it's okay I like that that middle
one that middle one no you didn't quite
make it I don't know what you guys want
uh try jumping on
it it has to be that one right right I'm
pretty sure unless it's between
no are we forgetting I'm like that fire
is singing my butt there's only two
spots it can be it's either that one
that where the tiki guy is shooting you
from or it's that square one over there
but I feel like it has to be the square
one cuz the fire is there and
I understand what you're saying okay I
understand
so I'm the strategist I'm not oh get out
of there get out of it space get Space
yeah good work that's great that's great
now go down okay now you can breathe
just kidding you can breathe just
kidding I got you can please take off
your headphones everyone good effort
good effort Mary I just want to say good
effort there's spikes
everywhere easy someone was over zealous
oh you're the clutch One how can we die
every every time even any of us can die
in this game go Whitey I was doing
really well before this level yeah oh
that was close this seems to be the
Bane this is
stressful the backstory of this game do
it the uh yeah the lore you're an
Explorer we're all the same person we're
just in different colors actually you
are the son of you doing it a an old
istan buul father oh that was fun who
refused to give you your inheritance so
you said f you Dad I'm going to go find
my own treasure [__] and that's what
we're doing that's that's the gist and
[__] I hate you Dad so are
wa yeah that's the backstory all
right easy on that
block all right who's who's going to go
I'll go I'm just going to wait because I
feel like it screws up the timing for
the person behind oh that was real close
I feel like I should just sacrifice I'll
go no let me sacrifice get it's so
stressful here we
go we wait let's go the two the two is
the best time the two is
the look like I'll go
first go
I thought on the two right
here what are we doing on the two on the
two we go on two that's the two right
there that's the two everyone knows we
go on
two all right you got to you got to like
commit oh you son of a can't still
triggered for your dead body that was
that's a
shame
easy
there good save good
save Yi oh you oh no
why all right let me go first and I'll
and I'll take a spear of man no let me
go son of a
be I'll hammer
him oh that was close I like the
patience I think yeah I think I'm
watching when his mouth opens yeah I
thought you had it I always think I got
it and then I freaking
die
the timing is
so
finicky Rob didn't like that W
for it freaks that was the double that
was the double we missed the double how
are we doing this I don't know we're all
here for the first time maybe yeah no
it's second time okay I'm going to go
all right do it all good
luck oh that was as close as
oh why did I do that I'm like watching
his mouth but it's very
fast I'm getting closer but I just can't
it's hard to like do the wad on go go go
jam it that was me I thought get in
front of you I was trying to throw one
in front of you remember that one shoots
I know I get that I'm very well aware
I'm the the moment you get in between
it's going to
shoot oh yeah he's got the timing down
feel the rhythm
the I don't remember the rest of the
words
oh you died that
time as
normal we're so bad this level shouldn't
take that long this level's tough It's
significantly more tough than the others
yeah it's making you do more things
right we haven't had to really do the
knife have won after getting that far
but it had so much more to it yeah I
mean like I think there's probably ways
to cheese this you know come on come on
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on come on don't worry just
uh we're waiting for oh nice somebody's
going yep I got this good luck good luck
yeah that's that second one's
tough sh I'm waiting for you man all
right you can't just throw them out you
got to time it you do you got to time it
oh I like that I like that that's a good
approach they walk like three steps and
then throw thing is you as soon as his
mouth opens you got to be hitting the
button okay it's not when it's fully
open because it shoots so quickly MTH
mouth mouth mouth mouth mouth yeah mouth
mouth rough it's so rough it's so hard
just to get to that
point uhoh sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
that that was me that was me I it was
like waiting and I was like oh [__] the
Block's
gone I fully admit that was me oh you
got singed you did get singed all right
you want me to go yeah you all right I'm
going to go after this is a bad time
I'll go when they're like two of them oh
wait all right here we
go we should go forward one by
one yep do it there it is I'm getting
better yeah definitely so it's not
spamming it's like
quickly but not all the time you're
getting it you got it you want to go
together cuz it's going to start
throwing at the same time ready go who's
throwing though oh all right I'll throw
I'll throw you stay behind there you go
I'm going to stay over here how are we
going to do this well you're going to
have to choose to go while you throw and
I'm just going to stay behind you okay
and unfortunately if you die I'll
continue that's like the only way we can
do it yes and then where do I need to go
uh you need to go across you go across
but that guy blows but that other gu
that hole that other guy's going to
shoot too though that's correct so it's
almost like if you guys can both make it
Max might want okay J sh I didn't expect
you to die I didn't expect me to die
either I wasn't ready I think we need to
just start doing
and all right
sorry
easy feel like they shoot at different
pace yeah they do yeah sure that first
one shoots pretty slow
oh yeah I'm
going good luck you've got the best shot
we're done too early we're done we're
not done to we're not done Max can do it
that's a good one [__] why are you all
going oh oh you had it to late one more
one more there you
go I've never gotten it this far and I'm
going to blow it I'm really proud of you
thanks and then the second
one oh I should have did a third I got
greedy all right you can do this this
part's really tough it
is I don't understand what your thought
process was that my thought process was
to go and try to throw at the same time
and the [__] yeah I didn't think that
one through either you know
what sorry I did it again I did I did it
again well we're going to beat this
level I promise you I just hope it
doesn't take 15 more minutes
yep Dream
Team Dre Dream Team oh I was part of the
I feel like I got old I aged or
something I'm landing Donovan uh you
know I wasn't good enough to make the US
team so I'm a commentator now 30 years
old you're too old it's like it's boom
boom boom like I think I got the timing
yeah you got to do the three I mean one
I did it on two one time that was that
was greedy one it's oh wait wait wait
wait wait yeah yeah I got you I got you
come on I'm going behind you okay we're
going to go after the next bike go here
we
go
okay you tell me when you want to go cuz
you're basically going to hit it and
then we R let's go oh [__] damn it why
did you jump I was I fat fingered
it that so T all right I wasn't prepared
yep wow living life on the edge there
oh you have time to get go down
and crushed
me I like your
patience hey dude I like to see exactly
what I'm doing that's smart I have a
heart attack from this game I don't know
if this is for me I'm going to go okay
easy now I'm doing don't worry about
it was too close oh you mother of I'm
going on this one what I don't trust Rob
I don't like Rob behind me look it
Rob ni riding your coattails to success
to every day all right after this Spike
we're going to
go I think the trick is is to hit it
book it Spike Goes Up Hit It Go behind
you you know all right after goes next
goes up go next time all right next time
next time said that like every next time
go oh
okay this must be so difficult for
everyone to watch I don't know I think
it's it's probably that was my fault my
fault my fault was and things like that
make it funny that was my
fault glad we all surviv good job
everyone I feel like I would just prefer
if you two survived me and Rob going
watch from the
sidelines I feel like I'm a detriment to
the team all right who wants to go I'll
go you go hidden in bookep Mary
2014 oh is that one or two two yeah yeah
but you got to progress yeah I'm going
you do it I actually might move
forward oh [__] wa wait wait sorry
guys I feel like it's even more
difficult with that many people going
that far personally all
right after this all so what I screwed
up last time is um I got ahead of you I
got ahead of you you and
Rob oh you got throw daggers oh right
the
dagers these things oh
sorry oh [__]
I got to progress I got to progress
getting getting
ancy that's how you die in this game too
is when you like try to go too fast but
I'm like so ready I'm so ready to move
on like a butterfly I just need I just
need to fly there it is I'm going to go
oh you should have went yeah there you
go oh good good reaction there you go
you got it great reaction [__] oh that's
a bad spot oh you totally you're in a
tight
spot oh both of you together with Rob
Rob does
it Well Done everybody all right this is
so bad I think this is worse real so
much worse can I go and just die and
just take a couple take a couple you can
only take one oh that's me I uh that's
fine that's fine just get me out of the
way please don't shoot just get me out
of the way just get me out of the way
there's too many see there's too many
people
see it's good you had three deaths to
figure it
out well there's I'm like dude I'm so
afraid of shooting
if St oh
go I don't want to stun
anyone oh you're real you're real nany
what is going on here guys guys guys
what is this m going on here
guys [__] it booking it I'm believing in
you Max [__] yes see I made it I know I
wasn't far enough I'm com give me a
second I'm com my head was too big I
domed it I'm coming give me a second I'm
on my
way the
one the two and the
jump do you want to go first sure if you
want me to I'm happy to do that all
right all right
and I
died I noticed all right you man oh man
oh he's living life on the edge living
on the edge oh you had it there
and oh I got excited I had it I I had it
I got it it's next time is the time is
it oh God feel like we've been saying
that a lot not for me it's not not for
me who pushed the block it could have
been me I don't
know so it was you yeah I so what you're
saying is yellow hat okay
me it's a bad one oh wa I'm
amazed oh
mother oh my
God just St I don't was that I don't
trust
you you you're not coming with us St me
and let me
turn of Ash wow you're holding you feel
how you feel then how we're going to
play it that's how we're going to play
it like
I don't like you want play like that cut
the dead weight you got cut the dead
weight oh my guy in the middle huh cut
holy crap I like C the dead weight got
cut the either you got to do the big the
big knife that
one Rob stay away from me Rob you
started Rob all right no
more I don't just I just murdered you
once saved your life I saved your life
all right truce
truce let's I'm scared guys oh
God oh my God Greg exotic we are paying
attention to what's on the screen what's
happening is we're getting anancy and
it's causing see like that kind of stuff
it's causing that to
happen a lot more factors too like white
hat white hat the wild oh [__] I can't
see I'm a wild card I can't see to go
time is
now a timing same result I believe in
Mary she came
Clos I I can't believe I got that far we
needed that one can we do a new one can
we we can try the other the other map
type the gold base
one all right after this try this is
last try this is it production is not
happy
production nobody's happy miserable
getting real tired of this
level it's like that one bloody
traveling level wild card what are you
doing down there oh my God I am not the
wild card that time you turn around Stun
Me Let Me
Burn God Max are you
going what is this game turn me into
what are you doing you got it you got it
I got it I got it I got just like
before
game is so just oh God I rush you man
you Ma this is your time to shine green
ranger best
Ranger always believe in Tommy you got
the timing down that's good play his
flute Dragon oh the spikes ruined it did
not have the timing down I all right oh
skip stage
oh Yi why didn't we know about that
hello all right hey all right well I'm
going go on through first you go ahead
okay guys let's see this all right let's
just check out what we got this is real
easy so far wow this real tough that
last stage was nothing this what's going
on I'll take the first one you know what
if there's no skip stage this is just a
troll w we might have to skip this one
too what if this is a troll that's like
oh wait no there's something there I'll
go first you've been going first I'm
scared what is that the key of
you got L artifact the
begar you got a now what okay let's
great you got it 50 up great job way to
go yeah yeah that was my favorite
stage what was that all of a
sudden they gave us a weener stage
because we were so
bad [__] sorry screaming oh wait wait
thank you thank you so much that was me
I know just like
that did you shoot me yeah he did to you
definitely
did hey no way you deserve nothing I
deserve everything Oh what now
oh how do I make this one you jump you
got to jump yeah wow wow that pure Lu go
now that was pure Lu yeah look at that
disgusting good I pan you're the worst
you deserve to
die I that there was no form of
comeuppence in that I didn't learn
anything oh my God what a Max who is
this
guy yeah shoot it you guys stay over
there oh [__] just keep shooting oh Max
oh sorry you were collateral
damage no I'm good I'm good where are
you huh sucker that's right I'm still
alive I can feel
it God I hope got to look out from
number one oh yeah if you're off screen
I think you die
yeah all right everyone just kill him oh
yeah this is how Mutiny
starts oh there it is nice good job all
right I'm not going to shoot if you
don't okay don't shoot me
y I got real tired of these upper
management yelling at me I can't start
taking them taking it into my own hands
you're a demon I
am I think to get past this part you got
to jump shut up
okay I'm going to kill you for real yeah
you got to jump right as it spikes
you're coming off yeah I thought I did
but I was a little early why did I
follow you why I I did that to kill you
well played then well played great
tactics I can't believe you made it that
far and then I lost with all the evil
that's inside your blood the game knows
the game respected that I I took matters
into my own hands
from oh wait I thought that
was God I'm so good
oh nice that
nice don't you got to go for that key
man yeah it's going to be a wait for the
spikes to go up no I can't even get it
you got to break the rock
for oh there it is o one
up that was pretty cool oo I like that
so you can't jump above the screen where
the screen doesn't show can you no you
no you can get to the edge though but
there's probably a spike there too and
then what can I can I I have to push
this block someone's saying fall through
I have to push this block that I'm
standing on you think wow yeah because
like look at how high I can jump I can
only jump that high with this block I'm
on so I'm going to have to push this
very
intuitive nice there you go little
scoochie scooch I think you can make it
Max you're the king careful that's going
to be a oh my God oh my God my
heart
I really hope that all these blocks are
going to fall I'm so afraid yeah I think
you're going to have to wait oh I know
what you're going to have to do you fall
you jump on that one as it falls you
jump on the next one there a nail biter
go what no you the she meant the other
one the other one the square one yeah
one the one to the left really
yeah
oh my God got a little itch you're a
demon got a little itch you're an
absolute got a little itch
demon the x button it's getting a little
itchy I'm going to wait for you guys cuz
the camera isn't coming getting real
itchy guys like that oh [__] no you
demon all right wait wait we need to
discuss this coming up we all have to
wait to the left because that block
ahead falls apart cross and wait there
we all have to die together or not all
right we I wasn't ready oh we didn't we
couldn't replicate what Max did they
died together that too early glad you
guys all died together well Max you know
the rest yeah exactly get it done
jeez see I like that what you want turn
it down
for
what oh I just died last shot all right
all right last shot go for
it yeah team dream it and believe it
it last shot after this I'm going quick
going we got one more after it that will
be going quick this is devastating you
you just make it just make it I believe
in you sometimes the non-thinking gets
it further
mindful oh there you go oh that's
amazing I'm in
a
a ooh that's balls oo he's getting balls
I think you can make it from just there
I don't care okay I know what I've done
you know what I'm saying so you're going
to jump to your right then you jump to
your left and then that block will fall
and you can jump off of that that's what
I Mak sense that makes sense because
there's no other way there's no other
way there's no other way and then short
jump long jump long jump and fire fire
miss the fire oh my good and they'll
fall those will fall and then right in
between the two big [__] squeeze in
between those big spikes that's a short
jump I think that's going to be a short
I don't know oh my you got this man
let's get through stage one first
there's stage one okay oh you might have
to yeah oh you don't even have time to
think go [__]
you last one huh production that was
awesome Max I for sure I was going to
don't worry guys I got this we got one
shot here he
says oh there's a spike there oh great
thanks oh my goodness oh oh come on
don't be like that last one this is how
this is how it's going to go
huh don't do that somebody killed T
sorry starting a little fight St a
little fight here woo truce all right
truce truce
truce oh son of a yatsi all right here
we go here we go he was waiting so he
could be the hero so sick of you Max oh
one up excuse
me you make me
sick this one's really fast so I don't
know what to do like
what right uh I'm bored oh you can put
your controller down it's over after
this oh I like
it should have you should you're
crazy you should have jumped up when you
had the chance I know whatever this is
it last chance Last Chance last chance
we don't care about what they say in the
back we can't stop us oh the stream's
supposed to end shut up I don't
care you guys I like that he used
me karma karma
karma we can't make it we can't that's
right we can't make it we actually can't
live no there's no way we can make the
jump at the
top there's no way that we
could so you're saying that it's first
come first serve he saying if we don't
all go at the same time none of us are
going to we
go screw you guys I got to
go son of a bum what am I doing Drop the
one below that you see that how you got
to time it right that's impossible I
love it I like it when you do that just
n the timing isn't there yeah no no no
no no no
no oh Mary was still progressing in the
level yeah
yeah well we were killing ourselves you
got to get the you have to go all the
way down to get the key that sucks
that's jump left jump left oh oh I
didn't think about it I didn't I need
the key I don't that's it I don't even
think you could do it that way see
they're still playing the two that are
trying oh come on to kill
someone all right we'll do it together
ready next one next one I just want to
kill them
sorry sorry uh goodbye Max goodbye Red
Ranger that was kind of cool
was just send it back to full screen get
us out of here he has no chance he has
no chance he can't go up there are you
guys all dead
yeah all right Mary you want to take us
out that was devastating and clearly
MVP MVP you want to share it those two
co- MVP I'm not sharing that oh
wow well the most humble award clearly
goes to Max um I would say most likely
to murder your there it is hey take that
off C take that off that's garbage wild
card should go to whitey to R Wild
rbin game hurt most likely to murder
your friends should go to Tay pretty
accurate right
there y y and let's see what they deem
me waiting for it no waiting for
it waiting for it nothing I get I get
nothing it is and I'm nobody I'm you get
nothing I know we'll see we'll see what
are they me
you what are you going to make me see
what it is so hot
wow wow Spar fingers rain it
in all right that's it for us thanks for
watching that was a thousand one spikes
I had fun I think uh would be better if
you're better at the game uh we could
definitely more practice but it was fun
you guys had a good time
recommended yeah cool so that's it for
us uh enjoy your Thursday uh and enjoy
your 4th of July uh go
America